my name is Gonzalo Ramos I am NOT Steven
Drucker he unfortunately couldn't be
here today but here's to Steve I'll be
facilitating discussion we have three
wonderful presentations that thread
through different aspects of
intelligibility transparency and debug
ability of machine learning systems
we're gonna structure this session with
three presentations and then at the end
we'll have a panel discussion for you to
participate and interact but feel free
also to ask questions at the end of each
presentation we'll have enough time for
maybe a few I'll tell you when to stop
if there are too many but other than
that I hope that everybody everybody has
a great time and a lot of ideas and get
generated in the mean time so we're
going to start the sessions with Dan
wealth he is a professor of the
University of Washington and the
Institute for artificial intelligence is
gonna talk about intelligibility in
something that I think is very
interesting in terms of using the metric
of teams being productive not just a
machine learning system model to be
super accurate is about more a human
centric way of thinking about the whole
theme so Dan if you may podium
[Applause]
can everybody hear me great okay great
thanks so much excited to excited to be
here and I want to talk about sort of
the key problem was we make AI systems
more and more complicated as they become
much harder to understand partly that's
because we're using complex nonlinear
models and and also because we're
training on on these very large large
data sets and I think this leads to two
key questions one is when can we trust
the AI system and the other one is how
can we adjust it when it's not doing
what we want so I think intelligibility
of our AI is what we're really after so
let me start by trying to define it
first of all I think of it as a relative
notion so we say a model an AI system is
intelligible to the extent that a human
can predict how it changed to the models
inputs is going to effect the change of
the output so Simula simulated bility
maybes not necessary but this ability to
answer counterfactuals I think is super
important I think we know and it tells
about modern when we see it so decision
trees if they're based on semantically
meaningful primitives and are relatively
small are intelligible but as the tree
gets big then then it's not and these
linear models again if they're over
semantically meaningful primitives are
intelligible the problem is that they
don't often perform quite as well as the
more complex nonlinear models and so
people issue them a third model that I
think is especially exciting are these
general generalized additive models
where you could have shaping functions
on otherwise linear components and we
can also bring in limited kinds of
non-linearity I think rich Cara Juana is
going to be talking about this so I'm
gonna skip that part so that's what I
mean by intelligibility and I think that
there's seven reasons why
intelligibility is really really
important in our AI systems Goggin
benzol and I wrote have a kakum paper
that came out a few
months ago and we go into those in
detail I'm just going to touch on a few
of them um so the first one is when you
design your AI system it's very hard to
figure out what the objective function
should be and oftentimes we end up
optimizing the wrong thing this is both
in machine learning and in planning
based systems so let me give one example
about personal assistants my colleague
Oren Etzioni and I built a personal
assistant many years ago they in
contrast to many of the script-based
systems we see with Alexa and Cortana
and so on used a planner to put together
actions to achieve the goal that that
the user specified in fact I was very
very proud that we were able to prove a
soundness theorem that this machine
could never make mistakes so that's
that's awesome why do you need
intelligibility if you've proven that
the thing is not going to make mistakes
well here's one example that came up you
can ask the system you know how much of
my disttoorigin I using for my photo
collection and the system came back and
it said none I just executed our MSTAR
and now I know you're using none so this
really is answering the question right
in fact it's a beautifully simple plan
that meant it didn't have to go through
and count all the different sub
directories but it wasn't really what I
intended so on the one hand you could
say well that's really stupid I should
have put in another sub goal saying
don't delete any of my files but the
problem is that there's an infinite
number of these sub goals in fact this
is an aspect of the qualification
problem that McCarthy and Hayes
identified many many years ago another
reason why intelligibility is important
is because your AI system may be using
and incorrect may be missing a key
feature and I love talking about this
but actually rich Cara want us I think
going to talk about it more salsa given
a third reason that's very dear to me is
that intelligibility facilitates user
control and here is an example from the
newsfeed application in Android you
can't really see it so I'll blow up at
the bottom and they've got some commands
and it's really saying you know why did
I get this story well here are the
reasons I got the story and furthermore
there
making those reasons and they're turning
them into commands I can say no I don't
want Netflix or no I don't want stories
from The Hollywood Reporter so those are
part of the reason why you got the story
and it's facilitating a command to the
user we've adopted this principle into a
new system called semantic sanity that
we've built at the Allen estufa a I
encourage you guys to to try it out it's
publicly publicly available and it's
free so what is it it goes over archive
and it gives you all of the research
papers that thinks you're interested in
and you can give it feedback so that it
very very quickly learns what you're
interested in in fact this morning I
went there to my human centered AI feed
and found this cool paper which I
haven't had a chance to read yet but is
is on my stack to read so I find that
this thing is indispensable as a way of
keeping up with with the literature
because there's so much stuff gets
published every day and I like to point
out that we've got this sort of
traditional kinds of command you can say
yes I like this paper no I don't like
this paper and we can learn a complex
neural model based on paper embeddings
that will predict which papers you're
likely to like but over here on the on
the bottom right we've got something
that works internally and it's going to
be a part of the publicly available
thing next week and that is you know why
did why did you suggest this paper I'll
come back a little bit later and say how
we built it but notice that it gives
these actionable explanations so I can
go in and say well actually explanations
are right and intelligible machine
learning is right but actually I don't
really care very much about autonomous
cars so I can just click on that and it
will adjust the feed based on the
explanation not on this specific paper
because in fact I did like the paper
sort of continuing this thing we're
seeing increasingly human AI teams and
the dream is that we're gonna be able to
go and only have errors that both the
human would make and the AI system would
make and so we can have higher
performance that's what that's what
we're after and intelligibility should
hopefully bring us to the stream much
more quickly of course we see
lots of AI systems out there that that
get updated and and they actually don't
lead to better teamwork in fact they
they deal with these AI specific errors
and get into serious trouble so this is
sort of trying to study this problem
we've been viewing a paradigm called a I
advised human decision-making is not
really the best buzzword but it's the
best we came up with and that the dream
again is if we improve the accuracy of
the AI then the improved decisions come
out where the human hopefully knows when
to trust the AI and when not to
so looking this update problem I'd like
to talk for a minute about some work by
a Gambon's all done with a bunch of
collaborators here at Microsoft Research
as well as Walter acequia at Michigan
came out as triple AI paper this last
year so again the dream is when we
update the AI system we're going to
improve the overall output of the human
AI team and the danger is actually what
might happen is at that time of update
even though the AI is more accurate it
breaks the mental model of the human has
and as a result it leads to reduce team
performance until eventually the human
understands what the AI is doing and
then presumably is able to get back up
to a to a high spot so one question is
are these kinds of incompatible updates
common because they happen all over the
place your Tesla autopilot updates your
Microsoft focused inbox updates are
these updates tend to be are they're
usually trained on more training data
does that lead to compatible classifier
or does that lead to an AI system which
is doing things very very differently
and here you see some experiments and
you can see in all cases training on the
larger training set led to a more
accurate machine learning system but
much of the time it made very very
different mistakes made mistakes where
the old system previously had the right
answer so if the human was relying on
that model they could get into trouble
and we did some some human subjects
experiments and show
people do learn models of how the AI
system works and if you have an
incompatible update then the overall
team performance goes down as you might
might expect and then finally as part of
this triple-a 19 paper we introduced a
regularization technique that tries to
maintain compatibility and there's a
number of different ways of doing it I
refer you to the paper but actually you
can get much improved compatibility with
really no no loss in accuracy in many
many cases okay so that's human AI team
excuse me as I try to move through this
stuff quickly hopefully lead me to a
good discussion afterwards um the last
method I reason I want to talk about is
for intelligibility is that you get
different distributions in the training
set and test set in fact often times
there's feedback loops which cause the
presence of an AI system to lead to a
different distribution of systems so we
see with filter bubbles and and other
things we get feedback from the human in
the loop system and we can lead to two
different different distributions and
that can lead to poor performance so I
don't mean to pick on Microsoft because
lots of people are heralding the
performance of their AI systems this was
specifically referring to a natural
language challenge problem called squad
where we're doing question answering and
you know here the question is who asked
Luther to disavow his writings does
anybody have the answer can you read the
Wikipedia page anybody okay so it was
Pope Leo the 10th and you know it's a
hard problem the fact that the AI system
can actually answer that question
correctly is pretty super impressive to
me and it does really really well so
this Microsoft Research team I think
actually now this people another another
system does even better but did better
than then human performs at least
Mechanical Turk performance it at eighty
two point five percent
exact match accuracy so that's really
cool on the other hand if you take the
exact same system and you give it a much
simpler question saying you know which
of these two students you know didn't
like science when when it says right
there Alice likes chemistry the the lsdm
model comes back and it says well you
know I think it was Alice it's like such
an easy question
and yet it's from a different
distribution you might think the AI
system should be able to do really well
on you know on simple questions as well
as the hard questions but the answer is
is no it's not so just being able to do
well on the test set is not necessarily
enough to trust the system when we
deploy it so to try to address this
problem
sherry Wu co-advised by Marko Ribeiro
here and Jeff hare at u-dub has built a
system to try to facilitate error
analysis of AI systems specifically
you're looking at natural language
question answering as one as one example
and if you look at the state of the art
what do people actually do in an ACL and
Knakal conferences well they're try to
understand they understand it's
important to figure out why their models
not being perfect but what they
typically do is choose 100 examples and
then group them into a bunch of classes
and sort of say well it looks like 32
percent of the errors are due to you
know the parser making a mistake and
there's a bunch of problems with us
first of all the air groups are
subjective so if you try to reproduce
that analysis later you get very very
different groups secondly we're only
choosing 50 to 100 examples that's
really not going to be giving us very
much confidence that we've identified
the true size of these different errors
more importantly we're focusing
exclusively on the errors it may turn
out that we identify a case where the
parser is going on where I'm actually in
most cases the system does well even
when the parser gets a mistake but it
but the distribution is different if you
look just at the error case instead of
the whole case and then finally there's
no test on the true cause
whether that's really is the cause of
the underlying cause of the air so
erudite tends to solve all of these
different things so first of all trying
to make these hypotheses reproducible
with a domain-specific language making
it so you can scale up and use a much
larger sample test not just on the
errors but also in the correct instances
and finally to to test via count or
factual analysis there's an awful lot of
stuff here so I'm going to skip most of
it but this gives you a hint of the UI
and the system is open sourced so I
encourage you guys if any of you do and
I'll Pete to look at it on the upper
left you see at a quick glance how well
your models doing in the lower right you
can browse through examples in the
development set in the upper right we've
got a little interactive panel where
there's a domain-specific language that
allows you to find new attributes and
groups in the lower left we can see the
distribution statistics over these
attributes as defined in the
domain-specific language too much for
you guys to graph all the stuff and I
won't go through the details but using
this tool we can go through and expect
the errors define these new attributes
discover groups where the air seemed to
be ubiquitous and we can hypothesize
that really is the cause of the error
and that's typically what a traditional
error analysis does the thing that's
nice is because we're defining these
groups in the domain-specific language
you can save them out and they can be
reproduced and other people can try
those same groups on their model as well
but I think the really interesting thing
is what comes next and that is what we
like to do is test and make sure that
that really did cause the error so in
this case we might have decided
incorrect pre-processing is what's
really leading to the air so the but
does that mean that if we do the
pre-processing better that that fixes
the error this is just one hypothesis
and I haven't gone through how we might
have come up with this hypothesis but
except that we found an example where
there was a date range and the - between
and there were no spaces and that caused
the system to tokenize wrong and that's
what seems to be causing an error in a
number of cases what we can do is go
through and edit our exam
and then see whether or not the system
gets it right and in this case it does
get it right so this seems to be
encouraging but notice that we're
actually testing our hypothesis about
the cause of the errors and what's
especially interesting is that erudite
allows you to automate these tests and
test them on a large number of examples
so there's an ability to define rules so
here what we're doing is making that
edit where we're adding in an extra
space and we're gonna run that over all
of all of the examples in our in our
data set and what do we see we see that
actually fixing the tokenization problem
only caused the system to get the right
answer 31 percent of the time so most of
the time the system still made an error
so this tokenization is not explaining
what's going on with our AI system I
went through that very very quickly take
suggest if you're interested you take a
look at the at the ACL paper okay so
what I've done is gone through some of
these reasons the ones that I find most
interesting about why intelligibility is
important but and here's what I would
say if you're out there building an AI
system first question you should ask is
is it intelligible is it built on one of
these intelligible models like the one
that rich Cara Juana is gonna say if so
go for it use it directly by all means
you should be preferring to do that but
there's a really hard question what if
that doesn't work for you in particular
what if you need more complicated
nonlinear interactions or most
importantly what if the vocabulary
you're using isn't semantically
meaningful and so you can't really
understand what's going on for example
if you're trying to do image image
recognition the underlying features are
pixel values but an explanation that
says you know I think it's a bird
because you know pixel 512 by 37 is
green that's that's not a meaningful
answer so in this case where we need to
use an unintelligible maybe a deep
neural model really what we need to do
is we need
to map to a simpler model which is going
to be an approximation explanatory
approximation and we need to map over
the explanations and we also need to map
over the controls and then the user can
interact with this simpler model there's
problems with this with this approach
because any times you do an
approximation you're not necessarily
telling the truth about what's really
going on in the AI but I don't think
that there's any choice if you're for if
you have to use that unintelligible
model to begin with so thinking about
this why would you use why might the
model you've chosen be unscrewed able so
one reason is because it's too complex
the other one is because it's based on
features that are not semantically
meaningful like pixels say where some
hidden layer of the neural network that
actually has invented its own features
that are useful for classification but
we don't know what those are so we want
to model do we want to map to the
simpler explanatory model and there's a
couple techniques that work so one
technique that's very good is to
simplify by currying and that's
basically instead of trying to explain
exactly everything that the doctor has
about their head in terms of medical
diagnosis let's just explain why they
made the diagnosis of kidney failure on
this particular patient
okay let's explain the instance not the
overall model and then the other thing
is simplified by approximating so maybe
we could choose a linear model or some
other screwball model and map to that
and then the other the other thing is
maybe the features are not semantically
meaningful in which case we need to map
to new vocabulary and I think that this
is actually a super super hard problem
and there's been a couple approaches to
it which I'm happy to talk about I
haven't figured out how to do it but but
other people have some pretty cool
research in this area and often times
you have to do both of these at the same
time so actually we have done it a
little bit so coming back to the the
paper recommendation system it's based
on a paper embedding
model that is is trained on semantics
collars corpus of 170 million scientific
papers and we're experimenting with a
number of deep neural models for the
actual recommendation and they're really
quite good but of course these these
models are not they're not screwed about
so if we want to generate an explanation
what what can we do we actually have
these two problems the model itself is
too complicated and the features based
on these paper embeddings are too
complicated so what we do is we come up
with an explanatory model which is
simply a linear classifier that
approximates what our global model is
doing and then we simplify the features
so instead of using the model embeddings
we use by grams which are pretty easy
for people to understand and then we
also do this currying idea where we
generate it and it's a specific
explanation so in particular with the
linear classifier we show what the most
influential features are for this
particular example the users asking
about not not in general and that's how
the explanation systems works okay so in
conclusion I'd like to argue
intelligibility is really important and
that there's many different reasons but
these are the seven I think important
distinctive reasons why you want to have
intelligibility in your AI system the
way you should approach fielding an AI
system is first always try to use an
intelligible model if you possibly can
and if you can't you have to map to a
simpler model and and there's a set of
techniques for doing that and in this
mapping you're going to be facing a
simplicity fidelity trade-off so the
original model is accurate is actually
what the AI system does but it's too
hard for a person to understand and so
how do you actually balance something
that person can understand was something
that actually is a good approximation
for what the AI system is really doing
there's three techniques simplified by
occurring by approximating and mapping
to a new vocabulary and then one thing I
haven't really
had much time to talk about is a lot of
papers about explainable machine
learning treatises let's generate the
best possible explanation but I think
really explanation is better thought of
as a dialogue so we really should be
seeking to build interactive systems
that provide an explanation but allow
this user to ask follow-up questions so
how can we think about interactive
explanations the the erudite system is
one way of thinking about that and then
finally very very important to allow the
user to test their hypotheses to see
whether that's really what's going on
with the AI system so that's it thank
you very much
I write minimizing dissonant updates and
then what I've been talking about as a
result of a really large number of
fantastic
collaborators I focused on the work of
gog and magog and sherry woo
but influenced by many many people here
so so thank you to them
[Applause]
thank you dan we have time for maybe a
couple of questions where we switch
speakers our next presenter will be Matt
but in the meantime we have a microphone
in the room if you wanna so let's let's
start with a path of least resistance
there was a person in the back there and
then the gentleman here I Pietro venucci
human computation Institute so Dan
really appreciate the talk it's a it's a
fascinating area and I think really
worthwhile and a difficult problem to
grapple with that said I I do find
myself wondering what BF Skinner would
say about this so it sounds like what
you're saying is that we have these
opaque systems that are producing an
output and we're trying to increase
transparency and intelligibility about
how they arrived at those to build trust
yet the approach we're taking sounds
very much like the black box approach of
we stimulate the black box this way and
we see what comes out on the other side
and and so and I understand the
rationale for that approaches these are
very complex systems and if we look
inside we might not really understand
what's going on on the other hand the
reason we took the behaviorist approach
with humans in the first place is
because we couldn't get into those
squishy systems and really understand
what was going on but we've built these
systems we know what the architectures
are and even if the representations that
arise through learning are
unintelligible at first glance I wonder
if there are methods we could apply for
example to to see what these
intermediate representations look like
the ones that are informing the output
of the system so I think you suggested
that there might be a feature layer and
if we look at those features they don't
seem semantically mapable to anything
specific on the other hand if those are
in forming a highly accurate output that
even exceeds a human output there must
be some semantic value to those and
maybe it's not individual but how
they're used in concert so is there some
way that we can remove this opaqueness
from the black box and expose these
intermediate layers as a way to
to start to approach true transparency
the concern I have about the
input-output model is that that often in
these systems these supposedly
deterministic systems that apparently
behave ended in non-deterministic ways
is is that if you ping you might miss
the edge cases and those edge cases can
be critical so I absolutely agree I
think that's a fantastic point so thank
you I actually think that's incredibly
important I'm not quite sure how to do
it which is one of the reasons I didn't
put it up there but that's not an excuse
I should have put it up there
I think the key challenge if specially
if you think about these neural networks
is the hidden layers clearly learning
something that's semantically meaningful
but today there's absolutely no reason
why there should be a one-to-one
correspondence between what is learning
at one node in the in the neural network
and some concept that in our mind has
has a name in particular it might be
learning all of the same things that
we're learning and we have words for but
they're all sort of rotated so there's
some sort of linear combination so each
one makes no sense to us even though it
actually spans the same space as our
concepts so we need to figure out some
way to train these neural networks so
that we can regularize again to get
those that the hidden layer so that it
actually matches concepts that we know
how to talk about and there are people
who are working on things like that I
think the way that the only approach
I've seen that does that is trying to
build up again a really large supervised
training set of sort of semantically
meaningful concepts and textures and
things like that for image recognition
and then trying to do joint training on
both the task at hand and this sort of
explanatory task so there is some cool
work at UC Berkeley Trevor Daryl's group
Lisa Hendrix thesis that does this I
think it's super hard to do but
absolutely very very important direction
thank you we're gonna just make it that
one question that was a good one but a
long one so we're gonna we're gonna call
a thank you Dan
then I'm gonna try to be brief and
introduce Matt of Kay from the
University of Michigan he's gonna talk
about the subject of
uncertainty and how it's a moral
imperative to communicate it to people
and this is especially important for
people that are not machine learning
experts and so on
take it away Thanks can you hear me is
this working
yeah great yeah so I'm gonna talk about
uncertainty visualization as a moral
imperative I think that uncertainty
visualization is important both when
we're communicating to lay users out in
the world and also when we're trying to
understand our own models and I'm going
to try to touch on both of those topics
but I usually like to start talks about
uncertainty by asking about what happens
when we ignore it so here's a
recommendation for how to communicate
uncertainty in scientific papers a mix
design ANOVA with sex of faces
within-subjects factor and self rated
attractiveness and oral contraceptive
uses between subjects factors revealed
the main effect of sex with face F of
one twelve seventy six equals thirteen
seventy two P less than point zero zero
no thanks reasonable alternatives to
this kind of thing might be something
like a regression coefficient table so
here I have regression coefficients with
standard errors I might do something a
little bit better so here's a
coefficient plot essentially the same
information is being communicated by
these two things but now I can easily
see magnitude and precision although
still I'm missing a little bit of
information I might do something like a
sampling distribution or a likelihood or
a Bayesian posterior depending on your
statistical flavor on top of that to try
to get a better sense of the fidelity of
the uncertainty here but really I want
to ask the question of how easy is it to
ignore the uncertainty and then I would
argue very I can look at this number
that dot or that dot happily take this
observe that this doesn't overlap zero
publish that don't publish that and now
we have publication bias this is
something that some statisticians like
to call dekada mania which is the
unending ability of human beings to
ignore uncertainty and just stick things
in buckets one of my favorite examples
of dichotomy Nia actually a lot of my
favorite examples of dichotomy Nia come
from elections these are probabilistic
predictions of Trump's chance of winning
the 2016 presidential election as of 538
gave them a 28 percent chance New York
Times gave him 15 percent and Huffington
Post gave them a 2 percent chance the
interesting thing is that still to this
day on Twitter people get angry at 538
for this prediction not only because
there was
I mean there's other things going on
here about why people are angry about
that but because they think that this is
a bad prediction but the interesting
thing is that 538 publishes calibration
data when they some say something is
going to happen about a third of the
time about a third of the time it
happens and that's what you want from a
probabilistic prediction so this is
actually not a bad prediction the
problem is the way it's being
communicated so let me show you
something different this is a risk
communication theater the story here is
I've given you a ticket to a random seat
in the theater I published the color the
seats black in proportion to Trump's
chance of winning the election if you
end up in a black seat he wins the
election if you end up in a white CD
doesn't I hope you'll agree with me here
that you'd be a little less surprised to
learn that you end up in a black seat
then when I tell you there's a 28%
chance and the thing actually happens
and so the point that I'm trying to make
here is that people are very good at
ignoring uncertainty but this is
especially true when we provide bad
uncertainty representations and we don't
have to so medical risk me or these risk
communication theaters are just examples
of icon arrays we use the medical risk
communication to communicate things like
chances of different possible outcomes
given certain treatments and things like
that we call these frequency framing or
discrete outcome visualizations of
uncertainty and there's a broader class
of these sorts of things that we can use
to try to communicate uncertainty more
effectively so one thing you might ask
here is how would you do this with a
continuous distribution this is just a
categorical distribution or two
different possible outcomes that was
something that I play around with a
little bit in my PhD so I'm gonna give
me an example scenario of something else
this is we're in Seattle so this is one
bus away it's a system in Seattle that
tracks where all the buses are in
real-time tries to predict when they're
going to show up at your bus stop so
this is telling me the bus number 120 is
going to show up 11 minutes from now it
has a six minute delay there is an
uncertainty presentation here if you
read down at the bottom it says bus
arrival estimates are based on the best
available information but actual times
will vary this is maybe not that useful
for me I were in Seattle I won't ask
this question do I have time to get a
coffee this is what the system is
telling me right now sometime between
now and the future your bus is going to
show up exactly a lot
minutes from now well it's just not
really useful for me to try to answer
that question what I actually want is
something like this so here's a
probability distribution over time to
arrive at my bus there's a bit of a long
tail there maybe it gets stuck in
traffic it could show up as early as
maybe about six or seven minutes from
now it's most likely to show up 11
minutes from Europe but this is actually
not what I want either what I actually
want is something like this if I show up
at the bus stop eight minutes from now
there's a 90% chance the bus comes after
me which is the same thing as saying
that I actually get on the bus the
problem is this 90% number is going to
change from person to person in
situation to situation maybe I really
want to make this bus because it's an
important meeting or maybe I know
there's some other buses coming or it's
a lunch date with some friends and it's
fine if I'm a little bit late so I can't
just replace this number with that
number on the basis of choosing risk
tolerance arbitrarily so what I actually
want is a visual presentation that
allows people to make this sort of
decision on the basis of their own
understanding of the situation and their
own understanding of the uncertainty and
their own incentives and so we're going
to try to build something like an icon
array for this distribution the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
take evenly spaced probabilities and
project them back into data space and
build up something called a quantile dot
plot and now what you can do is the sort
of counting based reasoning or around
uncertainties that you can do with
something like an icon array so I can
say something like wow there's 20 dots
here if I get there a minutes from now I
miss 2 out of 20 of the hypothetical
buses or it catch 18 out of 20 of them
so I have a 90% chance I'm catching the
bus I can do this with arbitrary
intervals down to the resolution of the
dot plot the other thing that's cool
here is that humans we can do this thing
called subitizing which is just that up
to about 5 elements in a collection you
can immediately recognize how many
elements there are there without having
to individually count them so if I have
a 20 and I mostly care about estimates
and the tails of the distribution most
of the things I'm doing I can estimate
using subitizing which is nice because
it's fast it's accurate and that's what
we found so we've looked at the ability
people to extract probabilities from
different visual representations their
error and it is generally better in low
density plots but then there's this
question with uncertainty visualization
that always comes up which is even if
you know how to extract the probability
from a visualization that you should
need in order to make the decision that
you want to make do you actually know
how to use that number to make that
decision so we run some other studies
where we look at things like we do
incentivize the decision making
experiments and then we look at decision
quality and I'm going to get into the
details you can look at the paper if
you're interested the the thing that you
see is that as people use assisted more
that uses this type of presentation
they're able to learn how to use it this
is showing me the variance in the
population so even bad performers get
better if you compare it to things like
density plots they don't work nearly as
well okay so we have this broad class of
discrete outcome or frequency framing
visualizations of uncertainty I'm gonna
give you a couple more examples of these
to try to sort of maybe stoke your
creativity and thinking about how you
could apply them so they're a simple
example so 538 after being continually
ambassador for this prediction even
though it was a good one let's look at
what they did in the 2018 midterms so
this is their forecast for the 2018
midterm house you'll see they're now
using the the top line thing that you've
noticed as soon as you look at this is
actually a sort of frequency framing
approach to communicating this
uncertainty you can still see the like
probability down here but this is the
thing that they're trying to make you
focus on this also comes up in hurricane
forecasting all the time so this is the
dreaded cone of uncertainty it's a in
this case I think a 95% predictive cone
or where the center of the hurricane
will be we have this thing called
deterministic construal errors that
often come up in uncertainty
communication where people will some
people will misconstrue
aspects of a probabilistic forecast as
being aspects of trying to trying to
predict something deterministic about
the outcome so here as you might expect
some people will misconstrue this as
predicting the size of the hurricane at
a given time point which it isn't right
once it makes landfall it starts to get
smaller so one option to this is to do
something like a spaghetti plot so here
I take draws of paths from predictive
distribution rather than trying to show
you this comb this is also nice because
you get a little bit better fidelity you
can actually see that some of the paths
while not very likely do go all the way
over here there's even a couple down
here which you may or may not be able to
see depending on the where you are in
the room you can do this with model
output so here's a simple linear
regression with a 95% confidence band
obviously I'm quite willing to ignore
the uncertainty here I'll just take the
line and assume that that's what's
reality is I could try to mitigate
against that a little bit I could do
this sorta so we got any pot approach so
here's 100 draws from a distribution
over these regression fit lines I could
instead do a sort of animated approach
so here we call this hypothetical
outcome plots this was something that
Jessica Holman introduced she's sitting
over there where you actually take draws
from this distribution and then animate
over them one of the ideas here is to
try to help people actually experience
the uncertainty to try to get a better
understanding of what's going on you can
also do interesting sort of estimation
tasks where if you had some threshold
you cared about you could do things like
count how often the line goes above or
below that threshold as a as an estimate
of some probability that you care about
okay so I sort of tried to give you a
whirlwind tour of some approaches to
communicating uncertainty from a sort of
probabilistic perspective I wanted to
take a step back from that for a second
so you've done a data analysis or fit
some models and you want to try to
communicate that to people maybe you're
writing up a paper or
you're writing up a report of course
this is what your data analysis looked
like your data came in and the analysis
happened and then your output came out
the other side and maybe it's a p-value
or maybe it's a like an F score or
precision or recall or some other metric
that you care about or maybe this is
some visualizations of results or some
predictions or what have you but your
data came in the analysis happen and
that thing came out the other side well
this is obvious obviously a parody of a
data analysis process it actually looks
something like this
you have different choices for say li
removal or future engineering or data
transformation or statistical models and
then what you actually had was this
combinatorial explosion of possible
analyses you could have done this is
model or specification uncertainty and
this is not necessarily probabilistic
this interacts with things like domain
knowledge this interacts with things
like whether or not we actually believe
the definitions of the things that we're
measuring correspond to the thing that
we care about in the world right this is
this is not just statistical uncertainty
so one of the one of the ways we think
about uncertainty in the statistical
realm is we have these two notions of
and depending on who you ask the
definitions here vary but I'm going to
adopt one that I like you have notions
of epistemic and aleatory uncertainty so
epistemic uncertainty is uncertainty in
what we know we might quantify that in
terms of things like parameter
uncertainty so here if I collected a
whole bunch more data my uncertainty in
the slope and the intercept of this line
are going to go down and this band
around that the line is going to get
narrower as I collect more and more data
aleatory uncertainty doesn't go down
it's predictive uncertainty so it's if
what's going to happen what do I think
the distribution is here at any given x
point for what a new data point would be
okay so that's all well and good we have
our notions of statistical uncertainty
we also have this thing called
ontological uncertainty how what does
all of this crap describe reality and
that's really what we're starting to
talk about here this is not necessarily
something that you can quantify
but you can try to deal with it a little
bit we're not okay so one way of dealing
with this is you do something like what
in social science we'll call free
registration and in what machine
learning we might call holdout set so
you at least define what this path is
you pick a model you pick all of those
things and then you apply it to some
data that you haven't looked at before
and you see what comes out the other
side but this runs immediately into the
problem of that old adage no good data
analysis plan actually survives the data
you learn something by applying this to
a holdout set you learn something by
applying it to new data and you actually
want to incorporate that somehow into
your analysis and into how you
communicate it and how you think about
it so the other option is oh sure just
communicate the combinatorial explosion
of all of this stuff right so here's
some matrices from paper that does that
each cell is an analysis and of course
at this point you're essentially reduced
down to well I have one metric that I
can show you so what I have this project
with some folks at INRIA and with
including Fanny chef oh yeah who I think
is here I don't know if I see her in
this room but she's here somewhere at
the summit so we had this thing called
explorable multiverse analysis reports
and the the idea here so we have a
webpage you can go to if you want
showing examples of some of these but
the idea is to get away from the sort of
fixed static presentation of research
papers and actually allow the reader to
[Music]
interrogate your paper in ways that they
might wish to so maybe in this
particular example you're interested in
different data transformations or
statistical approaches or confidence
levels you might even want to be able to
animate over the different possible
analyses in that multiverse
you'll notice here that the discussion
and conclusion section are not changing
as I do this so so this is not a
choose-your-own-adventure what paper do
I want to get out at the end the idea is
that you you still write the discussion
in conclusion to be robust to some of
these analysis choices but that you can
have a conversation with it via the
paper with your reader so you haven't
over another number of examples of this
how am i doing on time five minutes okay
so I'll I'll show too so this this
example is an interesting one there's an
infamous paper sort of near the
beginning of some of the replication
crisis stuff where some folks were
running kind of silly studies looking at
things like whether or not menstrual
periods had impacts on voting patterns
or religiosity part of the problem was
that there's a lot of ways of defining
what constitutes a different point in
someone's menstrual cycle and as a
result of this there are a lot of
different ways that you could analyze
this particular data set and make
different choices about what you think
those particular definitions should be
but the original paper sort of had this
interaction effect that they found that
a lot of the paper conclusions and
everything was written up around well
the interesting thing is that if you go
back and say well what are a number of
different possible reasonable ways you
could have done this analysis and then
do all of those combinations and then
sort of look at what they might have
looked like you'll notice that that star
doesn't appear very often when I animate
over the multiverse so this is one way
of again trying to interrogate the
reliability of some effects on the basis
of different ways you could have
reasonably analyzed the data the last
one I'm going to show so this is a
Bayesian analysis of some data for the
purposes of the example doesn't matter
too much what's what the analysis is
so one of the potential issues with a
Bayesian analysis is that my prior as
the analyst might not be the same as
your prior as the reader so why not
allow you to come in and interactively
specify your own prior and see how the
paper would update on the basis of
having a different priors so this
changes both you interact the
visualization here and then also the
text below describing the result okay so
part of the point here is that we need
better ways to acknowledge specification
uncertainty and have a conversation
about it through the literature I think
this is also true when we start thinking
about you know communicating results of
machine learning models and artificial
intelligence models I really been
thinking about this a lot in terms of
scientific communication but I think a
lot of these same principles would apply
in those areas as well which is
something I'd love to have conversations
with folks here about ok but I I like to
end this talk usually by going back to
election data because again like I said
it's one of the things that I like this
is the New York Times election needle
how many of you experienced the New York
Times election needle yeah so the
interesting thing about the New York
Times election needles of the way this
is actually working is on the on the
night of that election as returns were
coming in they had a model that was
updating every 30 seconds so not as
frequently as the needles moving to give
a predictive distribution for the margin
of the Republican - Democrat
presidential vote and then in your
browser that was updating every 30
seconds meanwhile this needle was
vibrating within the central 50%
interval of that predictive distribution
for what the vote margin would be so
this is essentially a form of hops or
hypothetical outcome plot it's trying to
use animation to show uncertainty people
did not like the New York Times lucky
needle
so my favorite one of these is done
right hand corner here
the New York Times needle jitter is
irresponsible design at best and
unethical design at worst and you should
stop looking at it I think that this is
wrong so the interesting thing about the
New York Times an election needle is it
made a lot of people anxious but I think
it made them anxious because they were
uncertain about something that they
cared about and if you're uncertain
about something that you care about you
probably should be anxious which really
just brings me to the end of my talk so
I think that one of the things that we
need to be doing both in communicating
results and in interrogating them
ourselves is presenting well calibrated
uncertainty that can't be ignored in
ways that people can actually understand
thank you so we have time for maybe one
or two questions while we switch
speakers rich if you can make it into
the and we have the microphone back
there so yes any of the uncertainty
definitions that you presented deal with
sort of complex output from machine
learning models say we're so much
focused today with predictions and
trying to do you know binary multi-class
but as we go towards content generation
planning path planning how do you expect
this uncertainty definitions to change I
I think that's a really good question so
I think in in in those cases if you can
generate distributions over those
complex outputs and I think you can
still think about them in a similar sort
of way where you you could say you know
what are some representative elements of
these distributions and then you know
giving some set of those that might be
interesting to people I think I think
that that's a complex question in terms
of the way that you would actually
present it as well but I think that if
you're thinking generally about
uncertainty at least in the statistical
sense or not like the second half of my
talk in terms of
how you construct distributions that
represent that uncertainty then you can
start thinking about how do I take those
distributions and maybe reduce them down
to representative elements and then
present those to people so this is
really really interesting I was curious
about the one bus away study that you
talked about is the conclusion that we
take from that that the product becomes
more useful in terms of the design of it
if it does give you this uncertainty or
is it simply that the product means not
useful until you get to a certain level
of certainty before you can choose
whether to get coffee or not
right I I think that's that's a really
good question so sure I mean if if the
system if the precision of those
predictions was on the order of like a
minute then yeah you probably don't need
to show the uncertainty right but I
think the the way that I would turn that
around is that's a really nice like
hypothetical question to which we're
never going to need the answer because
none of our systems are ever going to be
that accurate so so like that that's a
really great question if it was the case
that you know if a bus is 20 minutes
away from me I know that it's definitely
going to take exactly 20 minutes for it
to get from where it is to where I am
now but like traffic exists right and so
there's always going to be uncertainty
in that prediction and so it's always
going to be useful for me in that
context to have ways of presenting that
uncertainty to people unless I'm like
misunderstood your question the simple
version of my question is do people rely
more on one bus away if it shows
uncertainty even though they make better
decisions when they do use it do they
use it more oh okay okay so sorry I
misunderstood your question
yeah so I I don't have a good answer to
that because we've we've done lab
studies on it but we haven't done
deployment studies so that that's
actually something we're kind of
thinking about like you know doing sort
of experience sampling in the wild
to try to answer questions like that I
think you'll also get really interesting
questions that arise where you know if
if you know the uncertainty and the
system has communicated it to you well
and you could have made a better
decision are you now actually sadder
because you can't blame the system for
the mistake that you were gonna make
like I can't send the email that says
like I miss my bus but haha one bus a
place so terrible so yeah so yeah so I
think there's interesting like complex
questions that that start happening when
you see how that works in the real world
that I don't I don't have great answers
- yeah yeah
let's thank our speaker one more time
and I know we have some other hands that
left behind we're gonna have a time for
discussion so save those questions we'll
get back to those into time but now it's
time to hear from rich Khurana he's a
senior principal researcher at Microsoft
for AI has been working for almost a
decade on explain ability of systems and
he already was mentioned in Prior talk
so I'll let him do the continuation rich
thank you can you hear me
great - really good presentation so I
wish I wasn't going third okay so I'm
gonna jump in and talk about the risk of
using black boxes and the advantages of
using machine learning that you can
understand and I'm really going to be
talking about sort of debugging data by
looking at a model that's trained on
that data before I jump in I just want
to thank a bunch of people I think at
least two of these collaborators are
here in the room I think you Hannes is
over there and I think Erika is back
here so so at least two of the
collaborators are here but this is many
people grad students people who at
hospitals doctors who have helped us
with this a lot of collaborators over
the last seven or eight years all right
so let's jump right in I'm going to tell
you a story to begin with back when I
was a grad student at CMU I was asked to
train a neural net on a pneumonia risk
problem so imagine all of you have been
diagnosed already with pneumonia and our
goal is to predict whether you're high
risk or low risk high risk you
absolutely need to be in the hospital
possibly the ICU about 10 percent of
people with pneumonia die from it
so it's serious but if you're low risk
the best treatment really is as an
outpatient chicken soup antibiotics
calls in a few days if you're not
feeling better Hospital is a terrible
place to be
if you don't need to be there it's risky
especially if you already have one
infection I guess I got lucky the neural
net that I trained in the mid 90s was
the most accurate model any of the many
different teams working on this data set
could train so I sort of won the
competition and the question was was it
safe to use this neural net on real
patients to do some sort of clinical
trial and I said no I think it's
actually too risky to use this black box
neural net which has millions of weights
in it that we don't understand on real
patients and one of the reasons I was
afraid of that was a friend who is doing
rule-based learning at a different
University learn the rule from the same
data set that if you have a history of
asthma it lowers your chance of dying
from pneumonia that is asthma is good
for you if you've got pneumonia
okay so that doesn't sound right
right so we ask the doctors and the
doctors oh no that's not true asthmatics
are very high risk if they've got
pneumonia so you got to fix your models
so they don't predict that and then they
said you know we kind of understand why
that might be a pattern in the data
though and the story they said was Naz
Maddox pay a lot of attention to their
breathing they've got a med that they
would try and inhaler or something they
try it it doesn't have the expected
result they're already plugged into
healthcare they've got a doctor who has
prescribed their inhaler that they know
who to call when things aren't aren't
feeling right so they make a call the
doctor says that's weird they get an
appointment then the doctor realizes
they've got pneumonia they're considered
very high-risk and they get in very high
quality care so two very important
things have happened there one is they
get to care rapidly which if you've got
an infection there's nothing better than
treating the infection quickly and then
when they get to care it's taken very
seriously because they're considered
abnormally high risk so they get
incredibly high quality care once they
get there and those are the two things
that make the asthmatics look like
they're lower risk it's not that they're
intrinsically lower risk they're
actually intrinsically higher risk but
it's the quality and rapidity of the
care that they get that makes them look
like they're lower risk now I just
assume if a rule based system learned
this from the data because it's a real
pattern in the data then this thing is
lurking in my neural nets million
weights somewhere you might think this
is why I was afraid to use the neural
net actually it's not because what I
said back then was you know I'm a smart
guy
probably figure out how to make this
asthma problem go away in the neural net
now that I know about it and you know my
grad signal get to publish more papers
in the process of trying to do that I
said what really scares me is what else
did the neural net learn
that's similarly wrong and risky for
patients but something like a rule-based
system that's intelligible didn't also
learn this other thing and warned me
that I have yet other problems lurking
in the neural net that I need to fix
okay so that's what really terrified me
is the sort of unknown unknowns that
might be lurking in the neural net and
I'll show you in a few slides that there
were in fact other unknown unknowns that
we didn't know about then but we know
about now
before I go on what's the basic problem
here Dan alluded to it in his
presentation it's basically statistical
confounding right so we have certain
features in the dataset like whether you
have asthma or not and it turns out
those are statistically confounding with
some very important features that we
don't have things like time to care and
quality of care now quality of care we
probably could measure right we could
find out what treatment the patient
received if we have good medical records
time to care is a little hard and it's
probably the most important single
factor here it's hard because we don't
know when the patient came down with
pneumonia in the first place how rapidly
pneumonia progressed in the patient so
even in principle we probably can't get
time to care
there are even worse problems like we
don't have genomic data yet for all of
us
there's probably important variables in
your genome that affect your chance of
surviving from pneumonia and we don't
know them yet and all of that
information we don't know yet and
probably won't have in your record for
twenty years that is already confounding
on the variables that we do have in the
data set so there's confounding that we
can't even solve because it would
require future medical knowledge but
that's not developed yet so confounding
is not something you can just sort of
wish away you can't sort of decide oh if
I really had collected the data better
all these issues would go away and the
problem would be solved so we're gonna
have to somehow live with the data the
way it lies you might also think well we
just do a randomized clinical trial
right that's the sort of gold standard
for figuring out these sorts of things
so what would that mean that would mean
denying rapid high-quality care to some
asthmatics who have pneumonia to see if
they live or die right right so so it's
not ethical we're not going to do that
study so so you really have to learn to
live with the data the way it is and
you've got to decide to make some
progress using it and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna adopt intelligibility
as our way of dealing with this you
might think you could clean the data I
won't have much time to talk about this
but it turns out that's actually much
harder than trying to understand and
clean the model okay
by the way I won't have time to talk
about this this bias this asthma bias
that's in the data it's exactly the same
kind of bias that we have for race and
gender bias and socioeconomic class so
these very same techniques that we're
going to use in healthcare today are
also applicable for race and gender bias
stuff like that if there's time I can
talk about that at the end all right so
what would we need to solve this problem
a model as accurate as the neural net
that we wanted to use but as easy to
understand as a logistic regression that
would be great unfortunately there tends
to be this trade-off where the really
accurate models you know deep neural
Nets and random forests and boosted
trees are not very intelligible and the
more intelligible models things like
logistic regression linear regression
sadly on complex datasets are not very
accurate so we're looking for something
up in this upper right-hand corner
that's both accurate and intelligible
and to our surprise we now have at least
one algorithm that's sitting up there
that works on many data sets and it's
called generalized additive models with
pairwise interactions so I'm just going
to tell you briefly about this model
class and then I'll show you what we see
when we use it okay
these are linear models this is a wait
times the feature plus wait tons of
feature right pretty easy to understand
by looking at these weights and maybe
the confidence intervals around those
weights this is a full complexity model
it's just some arbitrary function of all
the features so think of that as a deep
neural net or a random forest there are
things in between this is a function of
a feature plus another function of a
feature these are functions but
functions of single features okay so
they're not an arbitrary function of all
the features that's a function of one
feature this is
a special case this is a very simple
function just to wait times the feature
this can be much more complicated it can
be a multi-modal very nonlinear function
of an individual feature turns out
that's a very restricted model class and
what's nice about it is it's
visualizable because we can plot these
graphs and you already saw one of these
graphs in Dan's presentation now we can
make that a little more complicated this
is all that this is the sum of all
functions of individual features that's
this this is the sum of all functions
over pairs of features so this can now
do pairwise interactions sum of all
functions over three-way interactions of
features and we're going to restrict
ourselves to just main effects functions
of individual features and a small
number of the most important pairwise
interactions and we're going to stick
with that class of models because they
remain interpretable to humans now we
didn't invent these generalized additive
models were invented by our friends at
Trevor hasty and Rob tips Ronnie at
Stanford in the late 80s so these have
been around for a long long time they
predate much of machine learning the
only thing that made them not sort of
win take over the world was
statisticians were very conservative
when they fit these models and because
of that they didn't get all the accuracy
and intelligibility that we now know how
to get out of them using sort of modern
machine learning techniques so our
contribution is to really put these
things on sort of modern steroids and
make them have a performance that they
never had before so that's our
contribution but these guys are very
smart
and they invented these these methods
these generalized additive models for
exactly the reasons we want to use them
today so this is really great work I'm
gonna skip all the technical details of
how these things work and instead I'm
going to jump in and show you what we
can see from models that are trained
using these things happy of course if
you're interested in what's under the
hood to talk about that this is this
pneumoniae dataset collected in 1989 so
this is a pretty old data set these are
the 46 features and remember the model
class is a function of a feature plus a
function of a feature so there's going
to be 46 functions of the 46 features
and then we're gonna throw in 10
pairwise interactions so there's going
to be 56 functions total and we have
things like the age of the patient
whether they have asthma cancer we know
their body temperature or their blood
rate what their breathing sounds like
we've done some blood tests and all
these patients have had an x-ray so when
a doctor is taking notes from the x-ray
so that's the kind of information we
have for these patients nowadays we
wouldn't have some of this information
we'd have other information but but this
is a good representative set of medical
information this was a great data set
back then it's only about 15,000
patients back then that was a huge data
set nowadays that would this would be a
very modest data set okay so this is a
function of the feature age this is a
function of the feature asthma a
function of the feature blood urea
nitrogen so each of these things as
graphs and I'll show you some of these
in close-up so basically what you do is
you find the patient's a door or your
age you read across the x-axis you read
the Y value the Y value is a number
that's positive or negative if it's
positive it adds to your risk your
chance of dying and if it's negative it
lowers your risk and if it's zero you
just have default risk okay so you want
to be as negative as possible and what
you do is you it's an additive model so
you just take a sum of all these numbers
so you take a sum and you get a score
and then you convert it in this case to
a probability of death by just one over
one plus e to the minus score okay so we
might get a score of minus 0.78 that's
not really good you'd like to be a minus
three or a minus four and this turns out
to be a probability of death of one and
three which is a very high probability
of death for many conditions okay so
that's the way the model works let's
jump in remember there's 56 of these
graphs I'm only going to show you two or
three of them let's jump in and see one
of these graphs so I'm going to show you
risk is a function of age first okay the
bottom is just a histogram of our
patients you had to be an adult so
everybody's over 18 most patients are
between say 60 and 90 okay so that
that's our density of patients this is
what the model has learned about your
risk chance of dying as a function of
age and it's an additive model it has
learned all 56 graphs in parallel that's
very important that it is learning these
things all together this is not a
marginalization plot it's something more
sophisticated than that so and remember
down is good so you want to be down here
up is higher risk adding to your wrist
so let's interpret the graph well let's
see it's it's good to be young
young seems to be anything under what
about fifty and the model doesn't seem
to distinguish between people are 20s
30s and 40s even though it could because
statistically it just doesn't see enough
evidence that people in their 30s or 40s
are different from people in their 20s
so this is all equally low risk risk
goes up sort of slowly as you go through
your 50s in your 60s jump in risk at
around 67 68 turns out that's retirement
risk goes up pretty rapidly as you go
through your 70s into your 80s I think
that's to be expected
surprising rise in risk right at 85 it's
a very interesting round number to see a
rise in risk surprising flatness and
risk actually throughout the late 80s
and 90s that's interesting and then our
really really surprising drop in risk
happening right at 100 101 okay so so
let's so let's talk about those things
so remember this is how the model has
learned your risk changes with your age
independent of all the other factors
it's also learned about okay so to get a
person's final risk we have to look at
all 56 graphs this is just one of them
this is retirement you might have
thought retirement was good for you
apparently not if you have pneumonia
there are lots of reasons why your risk
might go up if you retire it could be
your daily activity has changed your
rush to get health care might have
changed your provider might have changed
your insurance might have changed you
may have moved and not even having a new
doctor yet where you've moved to who
knows somehow in the aggregate all these
changes that happen around retirement
actually seem to lower your chance of
getting high-quality care if you're
coming down with something like
pneumonia which of course can masquerade
as a cold or a flu for a long period of
time so so it turns out retirements not
necessarily good for you for everything
this rise in risk that's to be expected
this rise in risk in 85 that's really
weird it's a very round number we're
pretty sure this is data from 1989 okay
so so back in the 80s being over 85 was
really very old right not that many
people live to their upper 80s and into
their 90's okay so we think what's
happening here is there's nothing in
insurance
policy or healthcare policy that says to
treat an 86 year old differently than an
84 year old but we think what's
happening is we're being a little less
aggressive for the very elderly patients
as in you know grandpa's 86 years old
has a number of comorbidities other
illnesses associated with being elderly
now because of those illnesses probably
grandpa's got pneumonia
maybe we're not doing grandpa any favors
by going for a third round of
antibiotics maybe maybe we should let
Grandpa pass okay and that was
considered perhaps a friendlier way and
and in fact then pneumonia was actually
called the old man's best friend
yeah you know sort of suggesting that
that that in fact maybe this was a nice
thing for very elderly patients who were
nearing the end of days anyway so we
think what we're seeing in the graph is
basically just a sort of less aggressive
treatment and vigilance for patients who
are over this very round number which
back then would have been sort of the
the threshold of being very elderly as
opposed to not quite so elderly so
that's our best explanation for that job
this flatness we think might be what's
called successful Agers people who have
pretty good genes and have made it this
far so people have taken care of
themselves so so maybe a person who's 95
and has gotten this far really isn't at
higher risk than somebody who's 90 a
dying from pneumonia if they get
appropriate treatment this drop at 101
that's the the killer
sorry yeah choice of words that's the
surprise and we think again right
hundreds a really round number and it
has a lot of meaning to humans right
because we do things based n like a
hundred is a centenarian it's a really
exceptional thing especially in 89 this
is an extremely exceptional age we see
more centenarians now than we used to
but back then this was a very unusual
thing and we think what's happening is
it's just like this social effect at 85
but now going the other direction as in
you know you've made it to a hundred
it's pneumonia it's a completely
treatable illness right right we are
just not going to let pneumonia be the
thing that takes you out right we're
just gonna go for it
we're going to go for the record you're
going to get that third or fourth round
abandoned by
if that's what we have to do we're just
gonna go for it and this is not going to
be the thing that that ends you and we
think what we're seeing is increased
vigilance sort of happening once people
get over this magic threshold of 100 and
we're seeing that that improvement in
their health care all right interesting
things about this model it turns and
remember the model is 56 graphs this
model is just as accurate as the neural
net in fact it's a little more accurate
than the neural net it's the most
accurate model we can train in the data
and yet we can look at the graphs and we
can try to sort of understand the
nuances of what it's learned now
remember it's us doing this detective
work it's not that the model has figured
out you know that a hundred means
centenarian that 85 meant very elderly
the model doesn't know any of this this
is just what the model has learned and
now we're trying to understand what the
model has learned and see if it makes
sense so now question how many people
think that a person who is 105 is
actually lower risk than a person who's
95 which is what the models telling us
right now I don't think intrinsically we
believe that's the case although we
could believe that's the case after care
is applied so one of the things we can
do because the model is a series of
graphs is we can have experts doctors
edit this graph and then the model will
do our bidding okay so we can actually
just modify this this model and now it
will not predict that people who are
under than five are lower risk than
people are 95 so that's great by the way
when we do that accuracy on the test set
goes down a little and that's because
the test set looks just like the
training set and the model is actually
rewarded for predicting that people who
are under five are lower risk even
though we don't think that's true
clinically and that if we were to use
predictions that said hundred and five
year olds were lower risk we might
actually injure some patients so so when
we make this correction our laboratory
accuracy goes down even though we
believe the model will do better in the
real world be more appropriate this
thing of 85 I'm willing to leave it in
the model our explanation for why it's
probably there is that we think patients
over 85 are getting less aggressive
treatment than they might benefit from
so if the model predicts they're higher
risk maybe that would cause them to get
more aggressive treatment so we're
actually happy to leave that in and just
warn doctors and patients about this and
you might want to stop being less
vigilant over 85 because we're seeing a
sign that that's reducing people's a
chance of survival and then this
retirement effect what we'd love to do
is just next time we collect the data
add a new variable for retirement and
then the retirement effect will move on
to that graph and then we'll be left
without this bump here in the age graph
remember this is a correlated graph age
cos correlated with retirement so
that'll move to the retirement variable
and that will have more of the intrinsic
risk associated with age
minus the retirement effect if we do
that so that's great do we always want
to make these edits suppose were an
insurance company and our interest is
not in intervening in a patient's care
but our interest is actually in just
knowing whether a patient's going to
live or not so we know how much money to
keep in the bank and charge for their
healthcare it turns out the model is
already pretty good from an actuarial
point of view so we don't necessarily
need to edit that's important because it
means whether a model is right or wrong
or data is appropriate or inappropriate
completely depends on what the model
will be used for what the predictions
will be used for okay
so you can't define right or wrong until
you define how the models predictions
will be used and that can be pretty
challenging actually so I won't have
time to talk about that let me show you
a few things the model learned and then
we'll wrap up jumps that happen around
numbers are all over in the graphs
they're almost always because of social
human policy effects there are very few
phase changes in in science and biology
and physics of course it learns that
asthma the lowers risk we expect that
it's a real pattern in the data but with
this sort of very accurate model we can
see that and then we can go in and we
can repair that graph we can make the
asthma effect go away easily in this
model even though we couldn't do it in
the neural net here's to fun things that
learn it learns that heart disease and
chest pain are also good for you if
you've got pneumonia okay so so in fact
the best thing for you would be to be a
hundred and five years old with a
history of asthma chest pain and heart
disease that would be a great low risk
patient so why does it learn this it's
exactly like the asthma effect it's
confounding if you've had heart disease
maybe you had a heart attack a few years
ago
or you're worried about a heart attack
you wake up with early symptoms of
pneumonia you think you might be having
a heart attack you're in the ER in an
hour
right you're there immediately even at
the hospital you get to the front of the
line they put probes on you and they
quickly realize you're not having a
heart attack and then later in the day
they diagnosed that you've got pneumonia
you have heart disease so they consider
you to be a very high-risk patient so
you get incredibly high quality care in
fact it's better to be a heart disease
patient than an asthmatic because they
get to care even faster than the
asthmatics okay so now the model is
rewarded for predicting all of these
things you know 105 year old asthmatic
with heart disease is low risk its
rewarded for that with like superhuman
accuracy on the test set but that's
because it's doing things humans would
never do it's only superhuman in the
sense that it's willing to do things
that no human who knows anything would
do so you got to be careful laboratory
accuracy is often misleading in this way
and I can show you a number of examples
where deep neural Nets trained on
clinical images also do things that are
very silly and non-human and if you were
to remove those effects their accuracy
no longer looks quite as wonderful as it
does good thing we didn't deploy the
neural net back in the mid-90s our fear
was justified there are other things
lurking probably in the neural net that
we wouldn't have known about we wouldn't
have known to fix you might think by the
way a way to fix this is to remove a
feature like heart disease or asthma
from the input of the model how can it
predict your lower risk if you have
asthma if it doesn't know you have
asthma turns out there's correlation
between the features that are going in
the model with things that you might
remove from the model and the bias is
all coming from the outputs from the
target signals from the training signals
not from the input features so it'll
learn to be just as biased as it can be
it will get it's heart disease asthma
fix through the other correlated
features so in fact now what we do is
variables like race and gender where we
might be worried about bias in the model
we make sure those are inputs to the
model we allow the model to become as
biased as it possibly can be because
that's telling us what's in the data and
then we can see the bias and then
because it's an interpretable model with
graphs we can edit the bias and repair
it okay I'm gonna stop there there are
lots of I just want to let me do this
one graph this is blood urea nitrogen
risk goes up as your Blin goes up all of
you have had a bun test it's a standard
standard to say when you get blood drawn
the doctor said you know this is really
fascinating and I thought it was kind of
boring because it just says that more of
something is bad for you which is very
common
the doctor said what's interesting is
they were all taught that 50 was the
level at which patients were high enough
risk that they should treat them and
they said what's fascinating is your
graph says the risk is already very high
at 40 and maybe we should be treating at
a lower blood level and they all looked
at each other and they said I don't know
I learned 50 in med school where'd you
learn 50 they all learned at the same
place it's a round number right doctors
use round numbers just like everybody
else does okay I'm just going to stop it
and this is just an example of most of
the things that the model learns ninety
ninety-five percent of what it learns is
actually wonderful stuff it's correct
and you're not going to want to edit it
but there is sort of five to ten percent
that's happening in these models because
it's in your data and that stuff really
needs to be detected and corrected and I
guarantee you every dataset you've ever
used has problems like this lurking in
it and once you have the sort of magic
pair of glasses all of a sudden you see
these things and you can fix them by the
way we've released open source code for
this so you can all train these kind of
models now very efficiently if you're
interested thank you thank you rich so
we're going to transition right away to
the panel where you'll have time to ask
you a question but will what let's
invite the speakers to sit in the and I
don't know how to call that the attenti
Fe theater okay of panic or the the line
or just give us a minute to arrange a
simile has a question for rich let's ask
it now okay so very interesting the data
is not 8 1989 so do you have you collect
a new data it's a wonderful question
we have not collected new data
specifically for pneumonia and there is
no doubt when I look at related problems
to pneumonia like all caused 30 day
readmission things like that we do see
that some of these patterns still are
true in modern data and other patterns
completely disappear yes
so so in fact the a hundred effect tends
to be less true of modern data because
we no longer consider hundred to be a
magically magically old paint like 95 is
the new 85 yeah very good and also a
related question is explainable are
those more applicable to the new data I
mean in a new cases or not right the
explainable model works very well with
the new data a one thing I want to be
careful of is this model works on what
Dan weld was calling you know semantic
data data where the features have
meaning to you if this was pixels then
this is not an appropriate model class
for pixels and this isn't going to
compete with deep learning and
convolutional nets on pixels and things
like that but for any data set where the
features have meaning to you then this
is a very appropriate model and it
competes neck-and-neck with visited
trees and random forests and and simple
neural nets so it's a it's surprising
that you can have your cake and eat it
too in this case where you can get
accuracy and intelligibility almost for
free yeah thank you let's have receipt
and this is a pretty quick experiment
remember Ken Hinkley and I'd working on
proxemics this is this is proxemics in
action yes sir hi I'm Peter Bert's lost
cake question to daniel although
probably relates to everyone else it I
you I conference there was a lot of talk
this year on this intelligibility and
explanation and turns out this is hard
to deal with neural networks approaches
which is really hard to explain in many
ways and several suggestions were using
examples showing people what this neural
models can and cannot learn an example
is actually not in your playbook on the
other hand if you look at the speakers
they really parades with examples if you
show visualization they show examples of
cedar filling which is a kind of example
from the human past and the second again
appealing to people understanding by
showing examples what could be learned
wrong from pneumonia so what are the
role of examples and using them for
explanations a new playbook
I think that's I think that's a great
question I think examples are really
helpful and so there's a good question
about what the examples should be and
there's a number of methods for example
of choosing out at exemplars from the
training set influence functions and so
on or one way of choosing choosing that
in a domain independent way there's also
ways you can do that in a model specific
way but I think that's a good good
technique there is work on explaining
complex models like neural nets by doing
case based explanation essentially
you're you're finding the examples in
the training set that look most like the
test point and then showing them to the
expert or the physician and asking them
to then sort of understand and you're
using the model as a distance function
so you're using what the model has
learned and you're basically asking the
user to say well the model thinks these
10 patients are very much like this
patient it just made a prediction for
and you're asking the user to then
understand the similarity between them
I'm sorry that's a version of this there
are multiple versions of this yeah
there's a thing called case based
explanation from the late 90s there's
also some modern work in prototype
selection prototype networks there's a
number of a number of variations on this
theme yeah the common thing between many
of them is you use the learn model as a
distance function so that you can do an
informed selection of the nearest cases
to any test point yes yes you you need
to have act if it's if it's gonna be a
case based like system then it has to
have access to the to the set of cases
it's one of the advantages of prototype
based methods is that they would
typically store a much smaller number of
prototypes than though all of the
original data yes I think I so I preface
this by saying that this is not my area
and I'm haven't been following it for
decades but the the notion somebody
talked about earlier
could you say more about that notions of
back in the 80s I remember that AI was
mostly about X
systems and neural networks as it was
this new thing that was not AI now AI is
from what I can tell us basically neural
networks and so the question is is there
a hybrid that would I can I can remember
actually talking to experts to elicit
models from them back in the 80s is
there a hybrid model that would allow us
to sort of model experts to establish
what the the hidden layer should be
about assuming that neural networks can
you know maybe there's several different
ways of coming to equally good solutions
why not seed it with the one that's most
likely to yield intelligibility later it
gets them more about that well I think
there's a number a number of different
ways of addressing that question but I
think it's a it's a good idea it's hard
to do certainly a key area and AI is
trying to integrate symbolic and neural
methods and that's gonna hopefully give
a more robustness as well as as some of
this interpretability another thing you
can imagine doing is could you learn
something like one of the GAM models
that which talked about over neural
neroli learned features I think there's
a bunch of things that one could try to
do active area and to add to that so
we're doing some work in trying to learn
a gam in parallel with a neural net so
the neural net will learn only the stuff
that the game couldn't learn and also as
you're suggesting trying to bias the
neural net towards representations that
are more and there's other work on
biasing neural Nets towards
representations that might be more less
distributed and more local as Dan
mentioned in his talk so there is work
on on doing that and then we view the
Gans and a human looking at them and
possibly editing them look we think it's
easier for experts not to tell you
everything they know but it's easier for
us experts to look at something and say
oh that looks right that looks alright
that looks like oh that's weird
and this one's just dead wrong we need
to fix it so so we think this is one way
of eliciting expertise efficiently from
experts is by actually showing them
something and then having them say what
they agree with and disagree with but
there's lots of as dan said there's lots
of different approaches to these sorts
of things it's not
saw problem though I don't wanna make it
seem like you know we've been there and
we've done it already so first I want to
thank all the speakers they're super
interesting stuff cutting across all
this the the one thing about which I
want to ask is cases where right and
wrong are not necessarily obvious so a
lot of the things you described like
when the bus shows up or does the person
die from pneumonia
like there is a yes or no answer it's
clear-cut if you look at instances
things like a toxicity detection in
online discussion there's a lot more
room for interpretability
and I'm wondering how the the methods
that each of you described how you might
think about applying it to those kinds
of problems where there might not be an
agreement or there might not be a
definitive ground truth for every single
data point yeah so I think I think
that's a great question I think those
sorts of questions have been a lot of
motivation or for me for thinking about
this notion of ontological uncertainty
and multiverse analysis right when you
start getting into complex social
questions where we don't have clear
answers we don't our your your output
the thing you're trying to predict you
don't even necessarily know what the
right definition of that thing is that's
a really good case for saying well we
can come up with a space of possible
definitions of this thing and look at
that space and try to understand you
know yeah is are the predictions that we
make the things that we learn are they
actually sensitive to those different
possible definitions or are there a set
of definitions that if you look at them
and say I mean I don't know much about
toxicity but maybe you put experts in
front of them and they say well these
particular set of definitions all give
us similar results and if we think about
the domain expertise that goes into
trying to define toxicity maybe there's
something about those definitions that
make sense right so so
I think it is it's this point where you
have to have the interaction between the
domain expertise and the models that
you're building to try to understand
that and it's it's hard to just kind of
sweep it under the carpet oh well
actually it's easy to sweep it under the
carpet but I think it's better yeah yeah
I would just add that that seems to come
up absolutely all the time so I think
it's a super important problem you see
people trying to take these subjective
decisions and make them crisper and
crisper so for example in the natural
language processing guidelines for
coreference you know whether one phrase
is referring to the same thing as
another phrase it's like 30 pages long
because there's always these ambiguous
cases Criswell tea has a wonderful paper
that came out in a magazine a few years
ago called truth is a lie which it gets
at this notion of there not being
subjective decisions in many in many
many cases just briefly most modern
learning methods are fairly good at
handling uncertainty and probabilistic
information so if we can cast it as a
probabilistic problem then we'll do okay
and we can make sure that they're
calibrated and things like that the
other thing is a lot of learning methods
can also do regression so instead of
doing black/white boolean probabilistic
prediction we also if we had a scale we
might be able to predict things along a
scale as well and that would allow us to
soften some of these things for which we
have less black white black and white
answers I have to have a couple of work
questions we have one on the back and
then one on the front well first of all
thank you for the very interesting
presentations to all of you I believe
most of the work you presented this with
offline learning where we have some data
and you try to extract some knowledge
from the data now would anything from
what you present it have implications so
would there be any parallels with a
real-time learning where you don't have
any data to start with and you're trying
to learn that optimal decisions from the
data as you acquire it for instances it
is in autonomous driving
can you comment on that please thank you
so we can't imagine gam learning being
modified for the online setting although
we haven't focused on that very much yet
so there's nothing in principle that
would make it not work and then you
would see graphs I really like the
multiverse kind of kind of plots you can
imagine that you'd be watching the graph
sort of percolate over time and you
could maybe replay the last month of
modifications to the online learning
system you know quickly and see if
there's been phase changes in the real
world concept drift and stuff like that
so there's nothing in principle that
would prevent us from doing it but
there's nothing magic about the methods
at least that I talked about that makes
them more suitable for online settings
than other things yep I would say the
same issues I think think apply because
we're garde 'less of where you're
getting the training data you still have
to choose the model class you should
still hopefully choose an interpretable
one if you can and if you can't if
you're gonna explain it you're gonna
have to use some sort of approximations
there is one weird thing in Ganz because
there are additive individual components
you can do something weird like the
model starts to learn something on one
of the graphs that you actually believe
is inappropriate and you think it's
because of some change that's happened
in the world and you can decide now
we're gonna keep using the old graph for
this feature while we allow it to keep
updating the other features and that
actually works pretty well so there
there is a little extra like controls
that you have in these additive models
because of their simplicity that you
wouldn't have in a neural net I don't
know how to tell the neural net keep
doing exactly what you were doing for
this feature but otherwise keep learning
and updating on all the other features
because I'm happy with the new stuff
yeah but we can do things like that with
simpler models like gams
yeah just amazing talk some all of you I
just had a question about communicating
the sources of uncertainties you said
you know there's a limit to how well you
can be sure the bus is going to show up
there's traffic very salsa's of other
things so is there a systematic way that
people have talked about allowing
experts to essentially communicate
pretend bear hypotheses
about sources of uncertainty and the
limits of nobility that you know we
might pursue also in the kinds of
context you're talking about the reasons
why retire retirement you wove a
narrative through this so it's you know
after the investigation and that becomes
a really powerful communications
mechanism is that our new kind of expert
elicitation system and how can you
communicate yes I guess there's a
there's a couple of things there there
is a sort of lung literature on things
like expert Pryor elicitation there's a
there's a nice kind of book by o'hagan
called I think it's called uncertain
judgments or something like that which
tries to summarize a chunk of that
literature which is a good place to look
at I think the other thing is that there
there are recommendations for how to do
qualitative uncertainty communication
you know as asking experts how good they
think their models are in a particular
area so so the IPCC the whatever the
inter governmental governmental panel
and climate change for example they
encounter exactly these sorts of issues
like we have these complex models we're
trying to communicate for climate
prediction the experts are assessing how
good they think those models are how
well they think they're agreeing and
then they have sort of scales for we're
trying to accumulate that and then turn
it into usually like a qualitative
statement of confidence in the model so
I think what's fun is there's a new kind
of uncertainty here which is an
uncertainty in the explanation and it
has at least two components one
component is just the fidelity of the
explanation to whatever you're
explaining in gams there's no fidelity
problem because the model is the model
is what you see is exactly what it is
but there's this new kind of uncertainty
which is how much do you trust your
explanation for why the model is doing
that because that hasn't a big effect on
whether you decide to edit the model or
not right if you sew that jump we see at
85 I mean all the patients were from
1989 maybe there was something in the
influenza epidemic of 1918
which caused that sudden rise in risk
and it's absolutely true for those
patients but only for that year and in
fact it has nothing to do with my you
know round numbers people over 85 or
extra old kind of analysis so whenever
we make this sort of interpretation
that's all on us to be detectives and I
tell you when I show these graphs to
doctors you know they're very smart
people and they'll come up with you know
half a dozen explanations for every
funny thing we see in a graph yeah yeah
so it's up it's up to us to track down
that uncertainty in the explanation and
because then we're gonna decide whether
to act on it and correct the model or
not which is if you're correcting a
model you're overruling the data that's
something you have to take very very
seriously just elaborating on that I
think if you're generating an
explanation using one of these
approximation techniques and you've got
that problem in spades so if you get a
nonsensical answer explanation out then
there's a very real question is that
because the explanation system gave you
know did a terrible job because it's an
AI system - right or is it because the
explanation system gave a very good
answer and the underlying model is wacko
and that's where I think Dan talked
about you know explanation should be a
dialogue as opposed to a single output
now I suspect that that would help a lot
with that kind of uncertainty yeah I
really like that you made that point
because I think when you start getting
into some of those more complex notions
of uncertainty where you want to
incorporate domain expertise or or this
sort of qualitative judgments it's hard
to just say I'm gonna give you an output
and then deal with it right like having
that actual conversation with the system
I think is important so I guess this is
it this is it this is all the time we've
got even more than so I am the only
thing calling you from lunch but let's
thank our fabulous speakers and
[Applause]